[Music]
pandemic nightmares twitter scandals and
the master plan to end all plans where's
phase four the mcu headed depends on
which universe you're in
kevin feige has never made it a secret
that he likes to plan out projects in
the mcu far in advance back in august
2013 he revealed that he had already
been discussing films in the franchise
that would release as late as 2021. the
following year he announced that marvel
had plans for motion pictures laid out
through 2028. in a 2016 interview with
collider feige confirmed that marvel
studios had specific movies in mind that
it wanted to release on a handful of
2020 release dates even then he seemed
to know just how phase 4 would pan out
viki has also been open about the fact
that sometimes these plans do change
such as the studios team up with sony to
produce the spider-man movies but there
are still always ambitions in place for
what the future of the marvel cinematic
universe will look like
rome wasn't built in a day and the
marvel cinematic universe was not formed
overnight speaking to rotten tomatoes in
june 2021 just as black widow was about
to premiere in theaters kevin feige said
that the prep work for phase four had
largely been done over a five or six
year period however he also pointed out
that other characters in this stretch of
the mcu had been gestating for much
longer than that specifically he noted
that the character of chongqi had been
worked on in some way shape or form for
10 or 15 years that's not just pr hype
from feige either back in 2005 the los
angeles times reported on the creation
of marvel studios and its intent to
produce self-financed movies it also
revealed that one of the characters
eyeballed for a solo movie was chongqi
welcome to the circus
of course this finally came to pass in
2021 with shang chi in the legend of the
ten rings the lengthy amount of time it
took for chongqi to reach movie theaters
isn't the norm for all marvel cinematic
universe projects but it does reflect
how long it took certain phase four
projects to come about
in april 2017 kevin feige explained that
plans were already well underway for the
follow-up to the mcu's third phase
though he was vague on the specifics at
the time he did note that there were
notions that the term phase might be
abandoned altogether a staple of the
marvel cinematic universe since its
inception feige explained to collider
that what followed phase 3 would be a
new thing part of that meant finding a
new term to revert to a collection of
marvel cinematic universe titles or even
abandoning the practice of grouping
together various installments in the
franchise in retrospect it's easy to see
why feige would harbor such feelings
given how avengers end game the
penultimate entry in phase 3 was such a
gargantuan game changer for the marvel
cinematic universe it would only make
sense that he would want to utilize new
terminology for how the various features
are organized however this potential
move never came to pass with kevin feige
officially disclosing details about
phase 4 the san diego international
comic con in july 2019
after the many delays brought on by the
kobit 19 pandemic phase 4 the marvel
cinematic universe began with black
widow in july 2021 however in an
alternate timeline phase 4 would have
kicked off with a very different feature
welcome to the frickin guardians of the
galaxy initially the first post phase 3
entry in the saga would have been
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 which was
penciled in for a may 2020 opening the
three-year gap between volume 3 and its
predecessor would have nicely mirrored
the length of time between the first two
guardians of the galaxy movies having
phase four kick off with a buzzy sequel
like guardians of the galaxy vol 3 would
also have proved hugely beneficial to
the franchise however those plans were
scuttled in july 2018 when james gunn
was fired from the movie after
controversy erupted over the filmmaker's
past controversial tweets with gun gone
there were initially reports that marvel
studios still planned to move forward
with volume 3 and get it out in time for
a may 2020 debut however gunn would
eventually be welcomed back to the
project though his commitments to the
suicide squad ensured volume 3 would
have to wait until may 2023 this opened
the door for black widow to take over as
the debut phase 4 film
as guardians of the galaxy vol 2 hit
movie theaters writer director james
gunn confirmed his intent to make a
third installment in the sci-fi series
while gunn reaffirmed even back in 2017
that this would be the final guardians
film he would write and direct he did
note that his influence might be felt in
the marvel cinematic universe beyond
that franchise speaking on facebook live
gunn revealed that he would be helping
to mold the vision for the cosmic side
of the marvel cinematic universe for
years to come referring to vol 3 he said
it will help to set up the next 10 20
years of marvel movies gun did not
specify what kind of phase 4 projects he
could be involved in though this
potential influence got sidetracked once
he was temporarily fired from guardians
of the galaxy vol 3. gunn's focus on the
dc eu kept him busy in the years before
he started shooting the third guardians
chapter though gun has yet to follow up
on whether or not he was able to exert
his influence on the cosmic adventures
of phase 4 it doesn't seem particularly
likely especially considering his busy
schedule outside of the mcu
years before kevin feige and the marvel
studios brass officially confirmed what
projects would make up phase four of the
marvel cinematic universe the rumor mill
attempted to fill in the gaps but it
wasn't until 2018 that a new concept of
marvel cinematic universe storytelling
emerged this was when variety broke the
news that marvel studios was developing
a collection of tv shows for the then
upcoming disney plus streaming platform
the outlet revealed that the small
screen endeavors would focus on
characters such as loki and wanda
maximol who hadn't yet received their
own solo big screen outings this news
was important for a variety of reasons
but especially because it revealed that
marvel studios was for the first time
planning on moving into the world of
television up to this point small screen
programming that utilized characters
from mcu movies have been made by the
studio's sister division marvel
television but with this new wrinkle in
phase 4 marvel studios would be
expanding its narrative horizons in the
process this early rumor guaranteed that
phase 4 was going to be unlike any other
phase in the mcu to date
phase 4's exploration of the world of
television goes far beyond the
mini-series however as the mcu is also
delivering certain stories as holiday tv
specials once the domain of rank and
vast programming like rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer marvel studios is
hoping to tell grander tales that can
also double as festive entertainment
tied to the biggest holidays of the year
the first of these projects was
announced in december 2020 the guardians
of the galaxy holiday special a
long-time passion project for james gunn
the production was confirmed by gun to
act as a kind of prologue to guardians
of the galaxy vol 3. with this reveal it
became clear that these holiday specials
weren't disposable goose but essential
parts of the phase four narrative this
isn't the only holiday special on the
docket for phase four either as an
untitled halloween special directed by
michael gaquino is also on the way
rumored to be based on the character
werewolf by night with these two
projects phase 4 has continued to
reshape the way in which the mcu can
tell stories on both the big and small
screen
when kevin feige first publicly spoke
about the prospect of marvel studios
making original programming for the
disney plus platform he was very
insistent that these shows would not be
removed from the continuity of this
franchise's movies back in february 2019
feige told comicbook.com that these
disney plus programs would be quote
entirely interwoven within the
theatrical slate to phase 4 mcu releases
this was in sharp contrast how previous
tv shows based on marvel characters had
tended to function by and large they had
been mostly separate from the
feature-length narratives in the marvel
cinematic universe and phase four the
franchise has managed to live up to
feige's words one division set the stage
for wanda maximoff's villainous behavior
and doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness while ms marvel sets up its
titular superhero so that she can serve
as one of the leads of the 2023 project
the marvels
black widow's elena belova showed up in
a guest star capacity on hawkeye and
it's fair to assume that the falcon and
the winter soldier planted seeds that
would one day be sowed in thunderbolts
perhaps most importantly jonathan majors
debuted as a version of kang the
conqueror on loki before stepping into a
much larger role in movies such as
ant-man and the wasp quantomania and
avengers the kang dynasty it's clear
that feige's mission to narrow the gap
between big and small screen
storytelling has very much come to pass
looking back on the phase 4 movies
announced that the san diego
international comic con panel in 2019
you can immediately spot a few
recognizable titles projects such as dr
strange and the multiverse of madness
and thor love and thunder were among the
most exciting to be announced at the
event but one phase 4 film notable for
its absence was spider-man no way home
this was despite spider-man far from
home opening a few weeks before the
panel and going on to crack 1.1 billion
dollars worldwide it would later turn
out that its absence was no mistake
esony and marvel were in the middle of
negotiations at the time over the future
of spider-man this would eventually
result in the two companies parting ways
in august 2019 with sony planning to
continue the exploits of tom holland's
spider-man in their own movies
eventually an agreement was signed that
reunited the two companies to produce
another solar spider-man movie resulting
in spider-man no way home
in the first three phases of the marvel
cinematic universe it was difficult to
figure out how the franchise connected
to the broader franchise of netflix
characters such as daredevil jessica
jones luke cage and iron fist while
these shows would often reference mcu
events or characters the movies never
returned the gesture once the marvel
netflix shows were axed in late 2018 and
early 2019 it seemed like this chapter
of marvel storytelling had come to a
close but then came the absorption of
marvel television into marvel studios
the two entities had previously been
wholly separate complicating any
potential crossovers between their
projects however now that they were
under the same umbrella small screen
marvel projects could be more easily
ingrained into the wider mcu an
especially exciting example of this took
place in spider-man no way home in which
charlie cox's matt murdock makes a cameo
appearance it was the first time a
netflix character had appeared in an mcu
movie but it wouldn't be the last
vincent d'onofrio appeared as kingpin in
hawkeye cox returned for she-hulk and in
2022 marvel announced daredevil born
again a disney plus series slated for
release in 2024
to bring to life some of its disney plus
programming the various branches of the
walt disney company have turned to
turning screenplays for unproduced
movies into longer limited series the
most high profile example of this so far
has been obi-wan kenobi which utilized
enough key plot points and characters
from a planned movie to give that
feature screenwriter a full credit on
the project hello there a lesser known
example of this trend can be found in
one of the phase 4 tv shows hawkeye
apparently hawkeye was still a movie
back when jeremy renner first signed on
but it would later morph into one of the
first disney plus shows created by
marvel studios the studio's ability to
transform a perspective movie into a tv
show with such ease demonstrates that
with its small screen projects marvel
has mostly been looking to make
elongated movies rather than traditional
episodic tv shows it also reflects the
ambitions of disney as a streaming
empire one that won't let any feature
film script go to waste
it's difficult to imagine that only one
aspect of phase 4's narrative was
affected by the kobit 19 pandemic after
all there are so many movies and tv
shows to juggle in the saga and so many
characters and intertwining storylines
and all of those individual productions
that surely a lot must have changed
right well apparently not speaking to on
the red carpet feige claimed that only
one significant change had occurred in
response to the pandemic for feige the
shadowy benefactor contessa valentina
allegra defontaine was supposed to make
her mcu debut in black widow in which
she appears in the post-credits scene
instead she turned up in the falcon in
the winter soldier due to the shifting
timeline that occurred as a result of
kovan 19. while it's doubtful that this
was the only change to phase 4's story
and formed by the pandemic it is the
only alteration that feige has so far
been willing to speak about
throughout the ongoing covet 19 pandemic
movie studios use streaming services to
debut movies that never before would
have been considered for small screen
premieres would new pixar titles ever
have been thought of as fodder for
straight to streaming debuts similarly
would a mammoth blockbuster like dune
ever have been given a simultaneous hbo
max launch in any other era the global
health crisis inspired unprecedented
action from almost every industry on the
planet so it should be no surprise that
the entertainment industry followed suit
well in 120 years of movies being in our
cinemas we've never had to shut down
like this before talking to rotten
tomatoes kevin feige explained that even
knowing how the pandemic had affected
movie theaters the feature-length
efforts from marvel studios were never
considered for streaming in the same
interview veige recalled how his
favorite experiences with these movies
involved watching them on the big screen
surrounded by enthusiastic audiences
considering that feige noted that he had
remained dedicated to keeping the movies
in phase 4 as theatrical events only one
film black widow had a dual release both
in theaters and on disney plus
while the mcu has a reputation for
maintaining a long-standing and reliable
plan for its productions the franchise
has often been forced to delay projects
under certain circumstances the avengers
was originally set to debut in july 2011
for instance before being delayed to may
2012. similarly doctor strange was
postponed by four months from its
initial july 2016 battle to ensure that
benedict cumberbatch could play the
titular superhero however phase 4 of the
mcu took the cake in terms of release
date shuffles largely thanks to the
ongoing effects of the kobit 19 pandemic
some films in phase four moved around
more often than others due to the
pandemic thor love and thunder was
especially vulnerable to release date
tweaks initially set for a november 2021
premiere when it was first announced in
july 2019 love and thunder would
eventually be delayed multiple times
including briefly scoring a valentine's
day weekend opening before settling on a
july 2022 launch date other projects
such as black widow and eternals also
received a year or more's worth of
delays due to the pandemic
for obvious reasons 2021 was something
of an odd year for the theatrical box
office features came roaring back to
movie theaters and many managed to do
solid box office numbers however with
covet 19 vaccines still making their way
across the general populace people felt
varying degrees of comfort with going to
the movies this and plenty of other
factors doubtlessly impacted the
worldwide box office returns for the
first three installments in phase four
this trioa project scored the lowest
worldwide box office halls for any
marvel cinematic universe project
outside of the incredible hulk the black
widow being only the second project in
the series to make under 400 million
dollars globally however there is some
context needed to better understand
these grosses for starters black widow
is given a simultaneous premium video on
demand debut on disney plus which
doubtlessly cut into its grosses even
more importantly none of these movies
were released in china every marvel
studios project released in this
territory from 2017 to 2019 exceeded 100
million dollars with all three of the
companies 2019 productions grossing over
150 million dollars in china alone a
standard theatrical box office hall in
china would have boosted all three
movies past the 500 million dollar
worldwide mark still all three found
some form of box office success and
particularly chongqi which was briefly
the biggest domestic movie of 2021
before spider-man no way home returned
the franchise to its former box office
glory i love you guys
thank you
for phase 4 the mcu marvel studios has
tried to forge even deeper bonds than
usual with some of its most important
talent this is in sharp contrast to the
previous eras in the company's history
save for a three-year contract in 2012
keeping joss whedon around to work on
assorted projects marvel studios hasn't
kept filmmakers under long-term
contractual obligations this has made it
extra easy for directors like scott
derrickson and john watts to lead
prospective gigs without having to
navigate how it might impact their
contractual obligations to the studio
but that has changed with phase four
with ryan coogler being the most notable
example of a director who opted to sign
on for the long haul as part of his
overall contract with disney coogler was
on the hook to oversee a new disney plus
marvel show set in wakanda at the end of
2021 it was announced that chongqi
director destin daniel creeton would be
humming a sequel to that movie and it
soon became clear that he had also
signed a long-term contract with marvel
studios sure enough in 2022 it was
reported that he would be directing
avengers the kang dynasty and overseeing
a wonder man series for disney plus for
phase 4 and beyond it seems that marvel
studios wants to keep a tight hold of
its most talented artists
[Music]